earlier this morning Army veteran Jake
Larson you just saw him was honored for
his bravery the 96 year old stormed
Omaha Beach 75 years ago today about
that for a second he says he is the last
living member of his unit Anthony Mason
who's leading our coverage from Normandy
today Anthony what a story he has to
tell good morning to you
yeah he sure does Gail Jake Larson has a
great life in California with nine
grandchildren and 11 great-grandchildren
but d-day was a moment that changed his
life forever and yesterday was the first
time in 75 years he stepped back onto
Omaha Beach 75 years how come I'm still
alive I'm still alive Jake Larson was 21
years old when he stormed Omaha Beach
with his army unit never in my life that
I ever think that I would be standing on
Omaha Beach on the 75th anniversary of
d-day it's like a dream come true like I
won the lottery the 96 year old vet says
the beach today looks dramatically
different the sea here is clear there
was bloody bodies what can a person say
now accepted wars he'll just think of it
a million minds out we follow us 2400
wrong yeah shooting at you yeah any one
time you stopped for a cigarette I
stopped for a cigarette behind that berm
and my matches were wet so I I turned to
my left and not three feet from me there
was a soldier and I said buddy have you
got a match and he didn't answer I
looked again and there was no head under
the helmet the soul of that boy
inspired me to aqua tech instant and run
for the clip how does it feel to come
back here J it's one of the most
unbelievable things can ever happen to
me I never figured I'd be even living
this long 96 years old is not chicken
feed no sir it's not
but Larsen almost didn't make it here
and it wasn't because of his age but
because of funding veteran organizations
were going to help but there was a
problem as quick as they found out that
my service records were burned up they
dropped me like a hot potato but two
women at his favorite coffee shop
decided to raise money for him through a
crowdfunding site when they told me they
were gonna put that on the internet or
someplace I said I'm gonna get one of
the chairs here and get a tin cup and
sit out in front now but you all pick up
more right outside here than you will
for that I said who is gonna pay money
for me go over there turns out a lot of
people didn't how did that make you feel
well it made me feel great because I've
got a book that I didn't know if I could
publish or not yeah but this is gonna
help me publish that the name of the
book it's going to be the luckiest man
in the world that's how you feel that's
exactly how I feel the motto of your
unit which is on a pin on your head I
believe yes to the last man you're the
last man that I am the last man yeah
what do you want people to know on this
75th anniversary J don't remember me
remember all those guys that sacrifice
their lives for freedom that we all
enjoy today and remember freedom is not
free
no it's not it was his friends at the
bagel street cafe in Martinez California
who started the fundraiser to send him
over to Normandy he's well-known at the
shop
Jake used to drive himself there six
days a week
that was until he couldn't drive anymore
he's a little grumpy about that fact but
he's great very grateful for this trip
guys so great I love him saying don't
remember me but now that you've
introduced us to him we will never
forget him exactly every beginning we'll
have to look for that book the luckiest
man in the world I love that he
considers himself that and so many of
these men who survived have all said
something similar to that you see why
people wanted to remember me with him go
ahead Anthony then remember and remember
you guys 96 years old is not chicken
feet no sir it's not they still got a
lot of he's very feisty guy I like that
I like that a lot of spirit Thank You
Anthony Mason in Normandy what a great
job you're doing thank you so much